and they they basically are just they
have a hard time dating they'll tell you
they have a hard time dating and even if
you survey men most would eliminate a
woman as a long-term Prospect if she's
an only fans and so really like what
what are what is society gonna do with
all these old they're not gonna
settle
um they're not gonna
um they're not gonna settle they're not
gonna
go down and die so what's really gonna
happen because they're not gonna get the
men that they want
[Music]
um and so I tweeted and this wasn't even
about Adam that's funny what do we do
with these only fans once they're
broke horse that no one wants to marry
in 15 years so I tweet that right and
Adam Adam comes back at me and says no
offense but you should be more worried
about nobody wanting to marry you right
now